[Music]
the Harry Potter movies are epic
but many important scenes from the books
were cut for time
whatever happened to Percy and Fred
Weasley keep watching for the scenes we
wish had made it into the films Ron Ron
[Music]
to see where Ron and Hermoine got
together in the last movie was great but
it wasn't what happened in the books in
the books
Ron revealed that he was worried about
the house helps he wanted to get them to
safety so they didn't lose any more like
Dobby Hermione throws herself at him
because she has cared for the elves so
much
Harry wonders if a bottle is the best
time for locking lips and Ron tells him
there's no time like the present you do
it that scene was changed because the
entire storylines surrounding the
Society for the promotion of elvish
welfare was cut hermione learns about
the mistreatment and enslavement of
house elves and starts a one-woman
movement she even made badges Ron
ridiculed her endeavor much through the
series in the Deathly Hallows part-2 of
all the more dissolved into little
flakes but many fans think that that
ruined his demise in the books his Avada
Kedavra rebounds during his final duel
with Harry in the Great Hall and who can
forget Harry's awesome speech during
that he calls Valda more Tom let's
finish this
Tom Riddle's body falls in a very
anti-climactic way this was deliberate
to show that he was really human a part
of Voldemort end here to die
another important scene that was cut
from the final movie involved in the
Elder Wand Harry didn't want the most
powerful wand he used it to repair his
trusty old one but he didn't break it in
pieces and throw it away he laid it back
in Dumbledore's tomb because he felt the
old headmaster was the rightful owner
just saying that's the most powerful
wound in the world
house-elves definitely got the short end
of the stick in the movies creature was
so proud that his former master Regulus
had tried to defeat the Dark Lord then
he was proud of Harry for taking up the
cause he rallied the elves of Hogwarts
to fight in the final battle he led them
out saying that his masters were heroes
it made up for all the mean moments in
the earlier books
the boy who stopped the scenes at the
wizard hospital in order of the Phoenix
were important but they were left out of
the movie Harry Ron and Hermione go to
visit Arthur Weasley after his attack at
the Department of mysteries they seed
Gilderoy Lockhart who has permanently
lost his mind but hasn't changed much
they also run into Neville and his
parents they learn how Valda more used
the Cruciatus curse on them until they
lost their minds
[Applause]
Ron and Hermoine x' romance wasn't the
only one the movies got wrong area and
Jenny didn't get together in the room of
requirements in half-blood Prince he
plants a big smooch on her in the common
room after a Gryffindor won the
Quidditch Cup Dean Thomas is furious
because he liked Ginny but Ron shrugs
giving his best friend and little sister
his blessing it was way more exciting in
the books because Harry just goes for it
can't you trust me Rita Skeeter might
have been perfectly cast but there's a
lot of information about her missing in
the movies the sneaky lying journalist
is actually an unregistered animagus
which was illegal in the Wizarding World
her animal form is a beetle which seems
fitting that's how she gets all her
scoops when Hermione discovers this she
keeps her in a glass jar for a full year
then she blackmails Rita into helping
them with an article to give Harry side
of all des morts returned today you two
may even make the front page no
professor had Harry Potter's back more
than Minerva McGonagall Harry had
immense respect for his professor and
head of house when Harry returns to
Hogwarts for the final battle The Death
Eater amicus Cairo spits in McGonigle's
face Harry is so enraged he uses the
Cruciatus curse on Caro then he says
that Bellatrix Lestrange was right you
have to really mean an unforgivable
curse for it to work no one messes with
McGonagall on Harry's watch
the movies never clarified what happened
to Wormtail aka Peter Pettigrew
Baltimore did given him a magical silver
hand after Peter used his real hand to
bring Baltimore back to life this hand
was a curse though in Deathly Hallows
Harry and Wormtail get into a fight
Wormtail hesitates before strangling
Harry
because Harry reminded the traitor that
he owed a life debt the magical hand
interprets this as portrayal to the Dark
Lord it wraps around worm tails throat
ending his life this isn't just one
scene that was cut it was several from
every book peeves is a poltergeist -
that lives at Hogwarts he's a trickster
who causes all sorts of mischief in
trouble some of his best scenes
involving Dolores Umbridge and also
helping fight at the Battle of Hogwarts
his entire character was left out of the
movies the Weasley twins are some of the
greatest pranksters and all of fiction
Umbridge came down on them hard in order
of the Phoenix but they led a resistance
movement of pranks they finally had
enough and caused a huge scene before
flying out of Hogwarts one thing the
movie didn't show was the swamp they
left a portable swamp in front of on
Bridges office all of the professor's
pretended they could remove it but once
on bridge left Flitwick cleared it up
easily he did leave a little patch of it
in honor of the twins we've been
thinking Harry we could always slip
Umbridge some puking pastilles into it
or fever fudge they give you these
massive pus-filled balls sounds great
guys
one of the funniest scenes in the books
is when the Weasleys meet the Dursleys
after Vernon agrees to let Harry go to
the Quidditch World Cup
Arthur Ron and the twins trying to enter
privet drive through the flue but things
go wrong when they realize the Dursleys
have an electric fireplace
Arthur inadvertently destroys half of
the living room and Fred leaves a
tongue-tied toffee for Dudley to eat I
think it's time you went in order of the
Phoenix Harry saves Dudley from the
Dementors Vernon blames Harry and tries
to kick him out of the house but then a
howler arrives from Dumbledore it
explodes and just says remember my last
petunia petunia immediately puts her
foot down and says that Harry can stay
Dumbledore's last letter explained that
Harry had to live with his mom's family
to prevent Baltimore from hurting them
which characters look too completely
wrong keep watching to find out the
movies leave out a lot of Tom Reynolds
backstory this makes it seem like Tom
Riddle becoming Baltimore it was random
but the books reveal that its mother
lived in two horrible conditions before
putting a muggle man under a love spell
we also find out that riddle collected
trinkets of things he considered
important his whole life this is why he
uses Horcruxes it's cold as I understand
it Neville Longbottom goes from shy
bullied boy - snake slaying hero but the
movies left out something really
important about him he could have been
the chosen one the prophecy talked about
a boy born at the end of July whose
parents had defied Baltimore three times
Neville's birthday was the day before
Harry's his parents had also faced
Baltimore three times baltimore
20-person aliy and Lily's love protected
him that's the reason Harry became the
chosen one the books could have been the
Neville Longbottom series but you will
cuz you're wrong
her hot dipping first for all of us
we've got another story line about a
house-elf that was left out of the
movies Winky belonged to the Crouch
family this elf helped a Barty Crouch
jr. and Goblet of Fire because she had
to do what he asked Winky also really
cared about him she put out the dark
mark at the World Cup when she was freed
she developed a butterbeer problem and
dobby helped her a lot at Hogwarts I'll
show you mine if you show me yours in
the movies
Remus Lupin and Nymphadora Tonks just
sort of end up together we don't
understand that they've met through the
order the book explains their
relationship in more detail we see a
fight between them because Lupin thinks
he's no good for Tonks as an old
werewolf the movie also doesn't show
that Lupin and Tonks have a baby named
teddy who is orphaned after the Battle
of Hogwarts I think I've known for a
while but I think you have taken one of
the biggest pet peeves of book fans
happened in the Goblet of Fire it might
seem like a small detail but people have
strong opinions about Hermione's dress
in the book Hermione wore a blue dress
to the Yule Ball and she went with
Viktor Krum Harry and Ron realized how
pretty their friend is for the first
time but for some unknown reason
Hermione wears a pink dress in the movie
we only get to see part of the
Department of mysteries in the movie
version of order of the Phoenix but in
the book this place is way creepier
there are 12 doors in the department and
we see a few in the book there's an
anti-gravity space room full of planets
there's the time room which is full of
time turner's and other magical clocks
there's also the brain room there are
tons of brains in glass jars and the
brains attack anyone who touches them
everyone was shocked to when Snape used
avada kedavra on Dumbledore but
Dumbledore funeral was left out of the
movie in half-blood prince hundreds of
people came Fox the Phoenix saying a
beautiful lament in mourning for his
master white flames appeared around his
body and cast a magical Phoenix in the
sky merpeople sang from the Black Lake
and the centaurs launched a ceremonial
arrows you meant a great deal to him the
movies leave out Percy Weasley's
estrangement from his family he didn't
want to be associated with them because
he thought that they weren't good enough
but he showed up for his family at the
bottle he and Fred were dueling Death
Eaters Percy cracked a joke which
shocked his younger brother just as they
made up Fred gets hit by a blast and
passes away this scene from Deathly
Hallows was actually filmed but it
didn't make it into the final cut the
Dursleys have to leave their home with
or wars because Voldemort could come
after them Vernon is thrilled to say
goodbye to Harry forever
Harry reminds them that Vernon called
him a waste of space Dudley shakes
Harry's hand and says that he'd done
anything yellow iced his face maybe
there's hope for Dudley after all see
you big day the first chapter in
half-blood Prince shows the muggle Prime
Minister meeting with the Minister for
magic we find out that only the Prime
Minister knows about magic and we learn
how he met Cornelius fudge for the first
time we also learned that the or or and
order member Kingsley Shacklebolt a
stationed to protect the muggle Prime
Minister Harry and Voldemort have one
important thing in common in the movies
their eye color was all wrong it's a
huge plot point in the books that Harry
has green eyes like his mother
but Daniel Radcliffe was allergic to the
contacts Voldemort was supposed to have
red eyes to show how far he'd fallen
from being human which is seen from the
books do you wish was in the movies let
us know in the comments thanks for
watching don't forget to like this video
and subscribe to the things see you next
time
you